[Musique]
et maintenant retrouvons une nouvelle
histoire de papy grenier
[Musique]
les enfants vous tombait bien j'avais
justement wingen schéma journée du don
au pape tu n'auras quand une histoire
une histoire est ce que je vous ai
raconté la fois où j'avais tué un gamin
qui l'avaient enterré dans le jardin
oui je voulais déjà raconté bon alors
est ce que je vous ai rencontré la fois
où j'étais dresseur de pokémon je m'en
souviens c'était en 1999 je crois tous
les enfants à l'époque voulait tabasser
des animaux pour gagner de l'argent mais
moi j'étais plus cool parce que moi
j'avais une casquette
je me souviens du jour où je suis parti
de boer palette tout le monde voulait
des pokémon tout le monde parlait tout
le temps de pokémon et tout le monde
était au chômage aussi je crois tout et
est en passe de pokémon les vêtements
les chaussures alors tu fais plus des
clercs la cua temps et comment vous y
développer une économie dans ce monde
comme ça comment imagine le bourreau
mais qui veut devenir livreur
je livre mes journaux je passe par la
forêt
[Musique]
pourquoi vous croyez que tout le monde
voulait venir aux us pour que notre
métier était bien trop dangereux
d'ailleurs quand j'y repense les gens
était bizarre moi je passais mon temps à
bouger dans les buissons et dans les
herbes mais beaucoup de jeunes de mon
âge n'aimait pas beaucoup bougé en fait
les montagnes étaient remplis d'enfants
immobile c'était flippant
oh là là on a perdu 2 138 enfants que la
première hybride arriver enfin bon c'est
du passé
le but de tout le monde c'était d'avoir
150 pokémon alors au début ça ne posait
pas mal de problèmes j'étais méfiant
[Musique]
ouais machin truc vous merde
pikachu à la bague au c'est pas celui-là
ma chère go c'est ce qu'une
jacky pas le dit ça va et c'est
bon j'ai des 150 comment tu veux que je
différencie y attend mince comment je
l'avais battu ses dresseurs déjà c'est
vrai enfin bon bref c'est pour ça qu'on
a décidé que les gens n'en porterai que
six sur eux
ah là là mais pokemon âge en avait qui
étaient géniaux mais j'en avais d'autres
qui l'étaient moins
je me souviens du jour où j'ai fait un
duel magique contre crise acier magique
et enfin elle crée ses attaques armure
qui s'est attaqué à sa durée ce compte
trois ans c'est vrai papilles non mais
ça aurait pu heureusement quatre jours
l'autre dresseur est mort de
déshydratation hop il avait 12 ans il a
bien vécu et quand même pour un dresseur
de pokémon c'est beaucoup
d'ailleurs c'était quand même vachement
lourds par moments et tous ces gens qui
m'agrée sait d'où le temps à la halle à
chaque fois que j'allais à la montagne
et j'étais obligée de tabasser tous les
gens que je croisais sur mon chemin
c'étaient des chiens
et en plus les gens étaient fous il m'a
approché en disant n'importe quoi je
comprenais pas bonjour je cherche le
collectionneur de pokémon de janat un
toit j'avais beau essayer toutes les
techniques pour les éviter il y avait
rien à faire je sais pas comment il
faisait pour me voir d'aussi loin a
pivoté vraiment passé comme ça bien sûr
que non officiellement en tout cas enfin
bon les duels c'était quand même quelque
chose on sacrifier nos pokémon jusqu'à
la mort pour avoir des matches et quand
on avait gagné contre nos adversaires on
prenait son argent c'était du racket
enfin bon c'est du passé et puis bon je
comprends pas cette polémique tous ces
gens qui disaient comprenait pas soin de
nos pokémon mais c'est pas vrai et c'est
complètement faux salut je vais faire
face à une vague est mort
c'est encore moi sony pokémon sa luc
émane de la place à des pokémon à
trappes
c'est bon les emmener à l'hôpital trois
fois par jour si ça c'est pas en prendre
soin je donne mon ressort et puis bon
c'est comme pour tout un finalement
c'est quoi un bon dresseur de pokémon le
le vrai c'est qu'on soit d'accord le mot
reviendrait sur les voies pokémon il
fait quoi
il capture capture et le cac a
d'ailleurs à cet endroit est le cas tu
l'as vu juin pour un vieux rock'n'roll
le capturer alors que le bon passeur oui
par contre c'est pas drôle il voit un
pokémon il le captur nous avons
rencontré seul by la bombe
c'est papa et moi et puis bon on s'était
pas de tout repos quand même un des fois
on était confronté à des obstacles
insurmontables
je me souviens de ce jour où j'ai été
bloqué en mon dieu
impuissant aux milliers de routiers peut
plus passer je suis complètement coq est
bloqué si je continue ce temps les
enfants mais papy c'est pas une richard
ça c'est un jeu vidéo au détrompez vous
les pokémon sont partout et nous observe
quand tu mets ton sac le matin pour
aller à l'école c'est un pokémon sont
partout autour de nos deux pour un
septième génération elle n'est pas qui
tu ne racontes encore une histoire bien
sûr mais ça sera pour une autre fois
[Musique]
et